That is video is going to be a bit
special.
It's a little bit difference.
We're not going to be talking about
politics today.
Instead,
we actually wanted to tell you a bit
more about visual policy itself.
In other words,
we're going to talk about this channel
because,
well,
we've got some important news to tell
you.
A few weeks ago we marked the one year
anniversary of this channel and today
we're well on our way to half a million
subscribers as every day 100,000 people
view a video.
Now,
whenever you start a new business or a
youtube channel,
there's always some risk attached to
that,
and honestly,
we all at visual politic felt that
starting a political channel on youtube,
it was kind of a particularly big risk
in forms rather than sensational
politics on any medium,
especially youtube is not exactly eight
super hot topic.
It's not an exciting blog.
It's not a gaming channel.
It's not even top 10 lists,
and quite honestly,
while we hoped it would do well,
we didn't really expect that the channel
would grow in quite the way that it has
now.
As many of you might know,
this is not my first channel.
In fact,
I have three other youtube projects on
the go right now,
so well now you might be wondering,
well what made me choose to start this
one in particular,
what made me think the visual politic
was a good idea and worth all of the
risk?
Well,
in this video I want to tell you that
story.
Wherever you're watching this video
from,
I am willing to bet there is plenty of
media coverage about politics.
I'm sure there are news outlets and
political talk shows of all stripes
satisfying both sides of the political
spectrum and I really don't want to
focus on criticism here because many of
these news outlets do trudy outstanding
journalism,
but in general there are a couple of
issues.
The first one is emotion.
The media playbook on politics as that
people who watch news do save to confirm
their views.
If you're conservative,
you'll watch conservative news and the
exact same thing goes if you are liberal
media,
Gary's will tell you that the way you
make politics appealing is by showing
emotion and also showing confrontation.
This is exactly why it's so many shows
tend to exaggerate their political
positions.
It creates a bigger conflicts.
Now the chances are you already knew
that,
but like I said,
there were a couple of issues here and
the second one is one that you might not
be so familiar with.
You see,
by definition,
journalists are focused on exceptional
facts.
Consider this aphorism from journalism.
A dog biting a kid is not newsworthy,
but a kid biting a dog is.
This has actually been the cornerstone
of political news since what kind of
since forever.
Let me give you a more real world
example here.
Anytime an oil tanker sinks,
this will hit the news on and on.
Go the extensive reports,
the interviews with experts and all
kinds of extended analysis,
but nobody's talking about the thousands
of oil tankers that don't sync all of
the thousands that simply make it to
their destination on a schedule and
without problems and display what you
might think from all that media
coverage,
those ships,
the ones that go on those regular
journeys,
they are the ones that have a far bigger
impact on your life.
Because I'm willing to bet that the
price of fuel for your car affects you
far more than that last oil tankers
sinking off the coast of somewhere.
But the reality is that we build our
perception of reality based on those
rare happenings,
not the normal everyday realities of
life.
And this leads us to not really
understand the reality of life at all.
And now let me give you another example.
This one with a bit more of a visual
politic flavor Africa,
unless you are a regular visual politic
view at your mind,
still think of Africa as an entire
continent full of poverty and misery.
And why is this?
Well,
that's because when a journalist talks
about Africa,
he talks about the exceptional things,
a war in Congo,
corruption in Angola,
starvation in Somalia and on and on and
on.
But economic progress,
it's not some exceptional event.
It's just something that ticks along
little by little,
day by day,
never really a big enough story to make
the headlines.
And headlines are what people read
there.
What people have been conditions to care
abouts.
And it's not just Africa.
And that's just a random example.
It's the whole world.
I mean,
Austin man on the street,
what the status of the world is today,
and he's probably not going to be full
of optimism.
Well,
it is war.
it's poverty,
it's corruption.
But do you know what the dog biting the
kid of this story is?
The oil tanker that arrives safely to
its destination?
Well,
as the simple facts,
but we live in the best time in history,
and this is not an optimistic dreamlike
viewpoint.
It's absolute reality based on facts.
We've got the growing middle class in
Asia,
rick clear path to the elimination of
starvation in Africa and life expectancy
is higher than ever before,
pretty much everywhere.
Oh,
hope is that if you're watching this
video,
you want a realistic view on the world's
not one salons.
It by popular media desperately needing
to show you conflicts and demotion,
and this isn't just about giving you an
informed opinion for the sake of it.
It's about giving you an informed
opinion because many negative elements
of society take advantage of people who
believe that the world is in trouble.
Very little is better than that.
Polarizing as society.
It's stirring up populist movements and
on the micro level even causing us to
make bad decisions in our day to day
lives.
All right,
so so far a lot of big talk,
but what does visual politic actually
have to offer you here?
Well,
we're here for context.
We're not competing with traditional
media.
We're not trying to get in that 24 hour
news cycle,
and so get me wrong.
It's absolutely great to be reading
newspapers and watching TV news.
They're going to tell you the daily
news,
so we're going to give you the trends
and the movements that are changing our
entire worlds.
This is why visual policy,
we'd love to compare one country to
another or dive into the history of a
situation in depth before we tell you
what's happening in the present day.
Context is so important and it's so
often missed by TV news because they
need to get the story that is breaking
that very moment.
It's the story that's breaking that
hour.
Even the story,
it was breaking that minutes,
but most important of all is that we do
this while keeping our independence.
Not every media outlet or even youtube
channel can say this,
but visual politic is 100% independent.
There's no think tank behind the scenes
writing checks.
This new company providing us with a
fancy office and there's no political
party peddling influence.
There's no hidden agenda here.
We publish our content in English and
Spanish and we are funded 100% by our
own resources.
Because I know you might be wondering
why throughout this video I've talked
about we rather than just I or me.
And that's because as you can probably
imagine,
there's a team behind me,
there's a team helping me create the
best content possible here with four
people,
if you include myself.
And if you want to see the other guys
behind the team,
check the Spanish language channel,
they present all of the videos over
there.
And this is not some easy job behind the
scenes of every video here.
This is between 15 hours and 25 hours of
research.
All of our sources,
double checks,
and we make sure that all of our stories
meet the highest standards.
Oh.
And then comes to the actual writing and
the editing and the recording and the
production and the channel managements
and as well on and on and on.
All right,
so at a very visual politic way,
let me address a few critics very
quickly because there's probably people
wandering in their minds now,
dia really have no viewpoints.
Do you have no bias at all?
I mean,
are you complete fuel and talking about
each and every issue?
And the honest answer there is no.
In fact,
anybody can be completely neutral when
talking about politics,
not even in theory.
From the very moment once opic is chosen
over another appoints already being
made,
it's just totally inescapable.
So with that in mind is what is our view
and what is our bias?
What I think it's probably best
described in a more positive light as a
principal and that principal would
simply be freedom.
We believe freedom should be an absolute
core value of politics,
more specifically respect for the
freedom and the civil rights of people
to the greatest degree possible.
Another principle we stand for is
cultural understanding.
We've consistently stated that free
trade between countries and cooperation
among peoples is the best mechanism for
peace and prosperity on a global scale.
As we've demonstrated in many,
many videos,
the evidence shows that isolationism and
protectionism do not lead to anything
good.
But finally,
almost important principle is not to be
dogmatic.
Everything we say is fact based and we
can have our minds changed if someone
gives us a good reason to change them.
This is why your feedback and your
comments are so important to our
projects.
You the viewer,
provide us with new information and new
sources and many of our videos are made
simply because one of you contacted us
with information about the country and
said we should make a video about it.
So all of that was a really long way for
me to introduce you to something that
you're probably already know quite a bit
about.
But now let me tell you something you
don't know.
Let me tell you where we want to be in
the future.
We wants to go further.
We want to make more content.
We want to make more videos in different
formats.
We want to go to different places around
the world and show them to you.
We want to introduce you to the people
behind the stories.
The people who really are changing the
world that we live in.
Oh,
and on top of that,
we also want to have our own website
with more official policy concepts.
In summary,
we want to take visual politic to the
next level and take this community that
we've built along with us and we need
your help.
Many of you have asked us already why we
don't have a Patrion page and the truth
is,
but it's something that we've been
considering for a really long time.
The truth is that we realized that if we
want to do more,
we need more and we need a way to do it
while maintaining independence and now
everyone else who wants to help us can,
if you want to,
you can join us in taking visual politic
to the next level and just quickly,
for those of you who don't know about
it,
patron is a platform that connects
creators with those who want to
contribute financially to that creator
below.
We're not taking anything away here
that's really important to say.
The classic visual politic videos that
we post every week on youtube will
always be available to everyone for
free.
But now for less than what you pay for a
beer,
you can make all our ideas,
more videos,
more specials,
so websites and even essentially books
or reality.
Further,
if you do contribute,
you're going to get access to exclusive
contents as well as plenty of other
surprises.
If you click the link in the description
box below,
you can check it off Patrion page and
learn more about the goals that we've
set.
And of course on that page you can
choose the type of commitment that you
might want to have.
And finally,
I'd like to use this opportunity to
thank you for your support.
Thanks to you,
visual politic is possible.
So to everyone who's watched and shared
our video centers,
music centers,
ideas,
left us comments while big thank you
from me and the rest of us now I'm sure
over the next year we're going to
continue to grow into an even greater
community with more possibilities and
without you on if that's possible.
So once again,
thank you very much and I'll see you in
the next video.